a message of support is what eu
commission president ozil of underlying
wants to convey on her visit to kiev
last night the eu has approved an
important ban on russian coal as part of
a new package of sanctions against
moscow the eu imports 20 million euros
worth of russian coal daily which is a
fraction of what it pays for russian oil
gas
measures also include an import ban for
russian timber cement and vodka it
prohibits entry for russian ships to eu
ports and a full transaction ban
on four key russian banks
let's get the view of alexander
rodnanski he's an economic advisor to
the ukrainian president welcome to dw
alexander
what are your thoughts on the latest
package of sanctions that the eu agreed
on
well thanks for having me well it's a
good step it's a step forward but it's
not sufficient so a sanctioning call is
about 4 billion euros in imports per
year that's nothing compared to the
overall fossil fuels and energy imports
that are coming from russia this year
it's you know projected to be somewhere
around 321 billion dollars that russia
is going to make by input by exporting
oil gas and coal to to europe now coal
is banned
so um you know that's the numbers and 4
billion in coal is really not sufficient
we need more we need sanctions on oil
sanctions on gas uh oil is is the place
to start oil is easier to substitute
away from
and that's what that's what needs to be
done there's other sanctions that have
been introduced on
individuals we'll have to see you know
the lists exactly but that's also a good
step forward
what makes you so sure that
targeting russia's energy sector is the
right lever moscow's war chest must be
filled
well that's right so russians the
russia's budget um
is sort of 50 or more than 50 reliant on
energy exports and so most of that
one-third of that is really due to oil
and that's the place to start that's
what we've been saying because we know
that gas is harder to substitute away
from especially in germany which has
made itself very reliant on russian gas
over the years and there is no lng
terminals there is no infrastructure to
start
importing gas from somewhere else so oil
is the place to start oil is easier to
you know substitute from the middle east
let's say there's terminals there is
infrastructure for it to be transported
so that's you know that's the obvious
thing but of course as you say so you
know there's also the other 40 or 45
percent of exports that are coming from
russia and those could also be targeted
things like metals chemicals other
things it's important to target exports
and not just imports into russia because
that's what's going to
devalue the ruble that's what's going to
depreciate the ruble and that's what's
going to drive up inflation in russia
and really drive home the message to the
russian population that this war needs
to stop so this is what we're this will
what we are encouraging and asking to do
alexander i want to talk to you about
the situation in ukraine despite the
fighting the war the hardship the death
is there still economic activity
yes there is still economic activity in
fact some of the economic activities now
resuscitating especially around kiev uh
because we've freed we've basically you
know hit back at the russians made the
russians withdraw around kiev in the
north of ukraine so certainly life is
starting to return slowly
and in some other areas the west of
ukraine has not been that badly hit
although there were bombardments of
course and still are but people are
still working so we see for example
agriculture is very much you know
there's production going on and now it's
the planting season and people are uh
our workers agricultural workers and
farmers are planting their seeds uh
they're even coming to our banks and
asking for
working capital loans so that's you know
we see signs of activity for sure
ukraine's defense minister has been
calling on nato members to provide more
weapons fast do you feel that there's
enough economic support as well
well we
we're grateful for the economic support
that we're getting there's definitely
you know economic support
for you know balance of payments there's
macroeconomic stability that we're
getting from the imf the world bank our
european partners the u.s so so far
we're holding up but of course going
forward what we will need is a big
recovery fund for ukraine in order to
rebuild our infrastructure rebuild all
the destroyed roads bridges and
buildings there's already an estimate
out there which i've recently seen by
the ministry of the economy which says
that we've lost about 120 billion
dollars worth of infrastructure for
comparison over the years from 2014 to
2020 the eu has granted us around 103
billion dollars for the construction of
roads bridges and airports so that's
just you know to put things in
perspective it has already been more
destroyed than what we received over six
years
thank you for your time